well I'll say one thing okay I'll I'll  let something out of the bag right now  uh uh I won't say anything about what it  is or whatever but uh uh I have written  a TV show I've written Eight Episodes  all right of a limited series I've  written all Eight Episodes I'll direct  all Eight Episodes uh I need to do a  Polish on it uh but you know that might  be what I like uh start setting up next  year dude you have a [ __ ] eight  episode limited series yeah yeah uh  That's so exciting and it has not you  have not sent out no no no uh no I like  my agents my agents read it and like a  couple people uh I'll be working on as  producer they're the only ones I've read  it this is breaking news yeah it is  breaking news holy [ __ ]